[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the consultant
editor of the daily mail andrew pearce
and the associate editor of the daily
mirror kevin mcguire both with us from
now until just before midnight
so front pages then let's start with the
metro and on the day of his sentencing
hearing the metro pictures the moment
former police officer wayne cousins
began his abduction of sarah everard
the telegraph carries the detail that
cousins apparently told sarah she was in
breach of covid rules as a pretence for
arresting her
that's also the lead story for the
guardian cousins used police handcuffs
and id
and the son has the headline sarah
didn't stand a chance
sarah's father's demand that cousins
look at them as they told of their grief
in court is the lead for the daily
mirror
and the times also leading on the same
comments look at us
you are the very worst of humanity
sarah's mother's words are on the front
page of the daily mail
while the eye focuses on the impact the
shocking murder by a serving officer has
had on women's trust in police
in other news on the front pages the
financial times hears that the
government plans to switch green
surcharges on energy bills so they are
levied on gas rather than electricity to
try to encourage lower carbon options
well let's bring in andrew pierce and
kevin maguire and we will certainly come
to those very moving front pages on the
sarah everard case shortly uh but first
i know you wanted to start on secure
stamina's day in the sun uh kevin uh how
did you think he did
yeah um i think he i think he did pretty
well it was too long the speech and it
swayed around at some time but he was
he was breaking both uh with the the
corbin pastor actually his own past
given me was back in public ownership
and he got elected the labour leadership
on a corbin uh corbin plan really uh so
i think he's gonna be held accountable
and uh
scrutinized on that at some point but
the guardian is one of the few the few
peppers to give it considerable coverage
on the on the front considerable space
because of the terrible sarah
everard case and i think uh kirsten will
understand why when those details can't
recall but the the line the guardian
take and i thought it was the best
single passage in his speech was when he
said that
boris johnson was a was a trivial man he
was a showman with nothing left to to
show i thought it was it was a very good
line because he's going to present
himself kia stomp and he is much to do
he's going to present himself as a
serious man for serious times and the
the prime minister attempt to portray
him um which i think will be accurate as
is rather trivial and with no plan yeah
did that work do you think the ft also
leading on this stalmer seeks new labor
i mean not necessarily the old new labor
if you know what i mean but definitely a
separation from corbyn and a nod to
blair and brown in his uh in his his
address today
well um i thought that the most the the
really that the speech was all about um
burying jeremy corbyn um burying jeremy
corbyn's legacy about jeremy corbyn's
manifesto um which of course
kirsten signed up to and and campaigned
for uh the last election but i mean we
get why he did that um and and he didn't
mention blair by name and i don't know
why he didn't actually because he made
that joke about uh i might education so
important i might mention it three times
that was one of blair's great slogans
education education education and he
praised some of the things that the
blair government did like the minimum
wage um and there was a reluctance it
seems by both ed miliband and certainly
corbyn to ever give any credit or praise
to the blair administration but the
blooming bloke won three general
elections he's been the most successful
labour politician in a hundred years and
he's been completely um trashed by
successive labor leaders so it's
interesting that stammer is
going to carve himself in that image
even if he can't bring himself to
mansion the bloke's name yeah the iraq
war is there is the is the problem there
isn't obviously for some uh daily
telegraph rather uh even putting the
labor leader on its front page he did
say
uh in one of his hits on government we
have a fuel crisis a pay crisis a good
supply crisis and a cost of living
crisis all at the same time so many
people perhaps are wondering why they
are not making more of an impact uh in
terms of their opposition to this this
government at the moment kevin
nobody acknowledged that uh as he said
however bad the tories are and he's
betrayed them you have to acknowledge
that uh labor wasn't doing better and
wasn't ahead in the polls he he
confronted that and of course one's
speech
is not going to completely change
british politics if he has to keep on
doing it day after day after day his
problem with ditching the
corbyn uh
legacy is that many of the corbyn
policies were popular such as public
ownership of uh rail mail energy
companies and water as were higher taxes
on wealthier people to pay for public
services enjoyed by everybody else a
sense of unfairness that
those those are the most money aren't
on pulling their weight and paying fare
so if he ditches all those policies
what's he going to come forward with
because he was pretty policy light uh
yes uh it was a very welcome uh proposal
that people with mental health problems
would see somebody on in the nhs within
a month insulation so on but there were
there weren't a lot of policies there um
we could never really assess these uh
speeches
uh fully until uh several weeks after
the party conference season to see if
they've shifted the dial
at all it may not he may go he just may
slip back kia stoma but the initial um
reaction by the public seems to be
favorable opinion research put out a
poll showing people liked what they
what they heard yeah
they suffer
they labor suffers long corbin as they
call it yes and we won't know um you
know what the impact of all of this is
until we have a next election to see if
the last one was indeed a brexit
election so that that that would be
fascinating when it comes um the metro
inside labour leader stammer faces down
towns from the left in a speech
signaling signaling an end to the corbin
era you know his lines on the hecklers
actually worked in his favor probably
didn't they andrew um but he thanked
loyal voters and activists for saving
the party from obliteration but said
they needed to persuade those who
rejected us those who reluctantly chose
to vote for for the tories um and that's
where the next election as we move to it
uh we'll show we'll
show where where where we stand on this
issue
it's interesting that metro they didn't
really
dwell in any great detail and what he
said in the speech because kevin says it
was pretty policy light uh far too long
and he's not a brilliant orator let's be
honest he doesn't deliver it with any
great panache but he dealt with the
hectors really well and i suspect he
he'd rehearse for some lines beforehand
and those hectares just played right
into his hands because um they looked
and sounded absolutely ghastly and he
put them down he put them he put them in
their place very well and very
effectively but whoever wrote those uh
non-spontaneous
uh put downs from kierstama in his
private office and did wrote them very
well
first time he's been able to uh speak in
person obviously the pandemic has in a
sense put a hold on people getting to
know him we did get to know him more
didn't we he talked about um the the the
stuff he'd got from his parents you know
service and duty and hard work will that
help do you think will it help inform
the media too on how they write up um
about kiestarma
possibly possibly anna um those of us
who follow politics closely those who
watch it on tv listen to the radio look
on the web by paper would know his
backstory because he's got to get it
across to the general public the
electorate and it's when
we
people like andrew and i and to some
extent you uh are bored have been
talking about his mother being a nurse
and he's a father a tool maker in a
factory when we're bored that's when
he's got through to the public so did
khan the london mayor used to go on and
on about how his father was a bus driver
but it worked because people saw that he
he done well in life uh from up from a
home where he had no advantages and i
think we'll we'll see
uh stomach time after time doing that
because he's talking about what guides
his life he said work care equality and
security which he picked up from his his
parents he's not just
gone into politics he had a life before
and i think people like that narrative
that story they want to know about their
politicians personality does matter
because it's whether you can trust
somebody or not whether the labour left
say you can't because he got elected
leader on one program and now he's going
for a completely different program
the problem is you hear toolmaker and
you start laughing now don't you that's
the problem yeah
well you do
i mean
what's funny what's funny about a tool
mate why do you laugh about it you have
to hear it in context don't you
thank you for now plenty more still to
come in the next part of our program of
course we'll look ahead to the
sentencing of wayne cousins tomorrow and
the impact on women's trust in police
statements for that
[Music]
okay what have we left on
well it's a start
well we wanted to create a character
that really tackled some very difficult
issues in the environment and climate
change but in a really fun and
entertaining and
it being light
for the kids to really engage with obkey
and to find some really good solutions
to the difficult subjects that we have
to talk about on climate change
i actually found and saw what the
environment and climate change is doing
to the ocean so for me i wanted to
create this character that actually is
based in the sea because i've seen what
climate change has done to our marine
life and
our oceans
i think what ocki's trying to do with
the tasks that he has and the topics for
example what you just showed on the clip
was switch it up which is the first
episode and that is showing kids that
you can save energy in your house by
turning off
the lights and electrical compliances
that don't need to be on
to save energy and it's finding these
topics um and explaining them in a fun
and environmental way so that the kids
can engage and actually
in the end
with their parents and with their
friends and communities to actually get
involved for example also one of the
topics that we have is
planting an insect garden and so you
know that is something that they can all
do together and it's not so scary we're
trying to take that away and make it
positive and find solutions for climate
change
[Music]
i
[Applause]
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now andrew pierce
and kevin mcguire welcome back to both
of you um so we moved to the sarah
everard case which really is dominating
the newspapers isn't it and uh today
made clear in in the most bald and
emotional way the terrible bereavement
losing a child like this andrew
yeah almost it's so sad to read it it
was just so distressing look at that sun
headline she didn't stand a chance
this man is so evil carefully planned
carefully contrived exploiting his
uniform to lure a woman into his car
putting her in handcuffs um convincing
her that she'd broken a coveted law by
going to dinner with a friend
and then the terror she must have felt
she was being driven out of london
towards dover
um she didn't stand a chance um it's one
of the most harrowing um sentencing
hearings i think i've ever read about
actually she's so such a beautiful woman
and for the mother to and the father the
way they spoke in court the father to
say look look at me look me in the eye
um
just beyond and it's extraordinary just
every even kevin's paper the daily
mirror which is a labor supporting paper
splashed this as the main story rather
than the kierstarma story because we're
all so shocked to think a serving police
officer could behave quite so easily and
that is the point picked up by many of
the newspapers like the delhi telegraph
for example that he used covert law to
entrap her and use the tools of being a
police officer which the public come to
believe means that you can trust them in
order to entrap her kevin
you know absolutely uh anna flash did
warren card used uh handcuffs would have
known um the law because he'd been on
patrol he wasn't he's an armed officer
he used to guard uh diplomatic uh sites
at the u.s embassy he'd done a 12-hour
shift there that day he used to guard
parliament
but he knew
how to go on patrol in that covent
period
and most of us uh trust the police to
some extent
but if you defy the police if a
police officer gets out with a warrant
card and says get in and get in the car
i'm arresting you and you don't you and
you're resisting arrest you could be
charged for that you could take it to
court you can just imagine how she must
have must have felt at that moment and
unbearable to try and think how she must
have felt later when she realized uh
that
he wasn't what he
appeared he wasn't a a police officer to
help or enforce the law he was a
a rapist and ultimately a
a murderer and the the metropolitan
police and i think all police forces
have a huge job now to reassure uh women
in particular after this and of course
he's been disowned and crusted a dick
the commissioner of the metropol
metropolitan police has has expressed uh
see deep sorrow and remorse that that it
happened but it it it's chilling it is
absolutely chilling because i think most
women if they see a police officer at
night they would feel reassured not all
particularly
younger women sometimes
depend on the circumstances or or women
who are black or a asian
heritage less likely to but by and large
the police are there to protect us in
fact
this police officer this vile police
offer wayne cousins kevin uh
apologies we're running out of time
there kevin andrew both of you thank you
so much thank you